la canada communal vraiment c'est une
sensation très difficile d'être dans un
dans une autre réalité dans le plus jour
j'ai vu ça dans leurs yeux
je le laisse se reposer pour le premier
jour à l'hôtel et je sais ce dont le
deuxième jour le dixième jour je le
prends ici à la maison internationale
pour faire tous les noeuds pap ainsi
tous les processus administratifs
on va on va signer tout ça c'est le
demande de programme d'allocation de
logement pour les réfugiés ils donnent
sur place ont besoin toujours de
quelqu'un parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
désinformation a en plus
ça va pas trop froid puis quai vallet
oui je vais vous évaluez je vais évaluer
votre santé physique
on veut
pas du tout fabricant britannique ozzy
fait notamment des jeunes
c'est ça on va passer au sol vraiment on
l'avait fait pour que les gens
s'installent ces légendes des réfugiés
comme welcome to the board du canada par
l ue
on est engagé à leur trouver un peu de
travail à faire même dose examen médical
les amis chez les aînés c'est amener
leurs enfants et aux écoles trouver un
hébergement
donc on prend les responsabilités
dhorasoo qu'est ce que j'ai trouvé c'est
que juste ils prenaient pas juste un
mois du dépôt deux mois c'est pas
autorisé je sais j'ai parlé avec les
propriétaires le mot d'analysé c'est
quoi la garantie sont des réfugiés la
motoneige ou un petit 40 et de plus on
accepte mais comme je vous ai dit un
moment donné c'est que les prix oui ils
ont augmenté
la pièce va pas du tout bien si
quelqu'un me sens chez moi ici pour nous
ce qui compte c'est la proximité la
proximité de sceller ses dires de la
femme de la pharmacie dans les eaux
internationales l'aide sociale c'est à
dire tous les les entités qui ont besoin
de données avec les prestations pour le
non le réfugié la lumière du cimmérien
je vous demande d'avoir une autre anzin
on a un rendez vous
de mes fils
les ouvriers tout magnanon contraire que
tout va bien a dit
ici ils vont placer la cuisinière de ce
temps quand il a fait signer des
chaussures tôt et avec des lots que vous
ça va faire de l'abattage rien n'est
parfait recèle autoritaire et ça c'est
comme noël
ok donc c'est bien important de nettoyer
s'est régulièrement lui donner des
choses la vie c'est des gens ce qu'il
faut ou d'un mémoire la douillette la
douillette
il ya un couverture des bébés keller
d'un débat bille en matinée ou s'offrir
la signature de travail à soyez vous et
où la nourriture
miam miam
non
ceux qui connaissent ça pour ça
on accompagne les lots bien mauvais
montrer comment ça fonctionne les
épiceries ici c'est quoi les raves et
les
les spéciaux et en plus ça valait permet
de voir l'organisation d'un supermarché
dans les salles et il voit aussi les
produits toute la variété de produits
qu'on peut avoir ici
il paye avec ce navrant mais c'est
l'argent du gouvernement
afin qu'ils donnent une île c'est pour
ça que lui fait très attention à ce
qu'il peut prendre parce que maintenant
il sait que celui/celle madame madame
non à la haine ni guéri et wall street
face
obligé d'être drôle
l'intervention s'est jamais la même
situation
aucune famille tout se joue souvent les
premières minutes refuse arrive ici
quand il arrive la première journée
c'est toute l'âme on ressent quand la
fatigue l'épuisement qu'ils ont eues
durant les vols les démarches
administratives tout ça mais le plus
gros c'est tout ce qui en arrière tout
ce à quoi ils pensent le deuil qui doit
faire de leur pays de tout ce qu'ils ont
laissé ce de ce qu'ils ont fuies
également qui fait plus mal en fait pour
eux ça commence le parcours du
combattant qu'est
je voudrais le voyais pas sur le champ
c'est prêt vital est très important